foreign
we are back and uh it's time for drum
roll please uh lightning round another
look at that way to go way to go Ben
with the jamming Tunes uh it's lightning
round y'all loved it the last time we
did it so we're doing it again as a
reminder Kelly Cuts me off to get a
minute
roughly roughly until Kelly gets tired
of listening to me and I have no idea
zero I've got no idea what these
questions are where they're coming from
who's asking Jenna or Kelly me okay and
they're about what these are all about
relationships thematically yes
are you gonna ask me about what happens
when a producer takes over a show and
they're just mean you can ask me that
question no I know how that relationship
ends yeah I don't know how to I don't
know how to handle that that wouldn't be
good these are all pretty much about
marital relationships marital dating
that kind of thing okay you got it
that's all I'm giving you and I wish
y'all could see she's got a smile on her
face because she knows she's gonna lob
grenades in here and I can't do anything
about it and I only get a minute and I
talk too long anyway okay let's do this
I'm ready
all right question one what advice would
you give to a young single male looking
for a relationship make yourself the
best version of you you can be
quit trying to figure out find other
people to make you feel good about
yourself go exercise go get a great job
go get a couple of mentors go do big
things go out swing and go join an MMA
gym go do stuff go join a violin class
or a guitar class or a salsa dancing or
knitting I don't care what you do go
make yourself the best version of you
you can be so that when you run into
somebody they don't look at you as a
project they look at you as a yes please
look at you 30 seconds left really yeah
that's the first time ever ever all
right next question is that a good
answer what do you think about that
actually I think that was fantastic
worry about you not about getting in the
relationship I think that's a fantastic
answer
yes all right what do you do when one
spouse is ready to have kids or adopt
and the other isn't
leave them
divorce probably
I'm just kidding the only way that's the
only way and that's the last time we do
this no don't do that okay what's the
question again
what do you do when one spouse is ready
to leave or to have kids or adopt and
the other one isn't
I think
the decision to have kids or not have
kids is one of the core challenges
um that all relationship all marriage
relationships face and I think it's
getting to the core of that
um underneath it I'm put on Earth to be
a mom I really want to be a dad
um my life isn't full without what is
what are you afraid of I think getting
to those things and really being very
very specific what are the core fears
one of each one of you who doesn't want
to have kids what are the core fears
what are the core Pros like here's what
I really want to have children and
getting to the core of that stuff and
then at some point and it sounds awful
you got to negotiate let's I need six
months and let's figure it out all right
the timers all right
how do you the next question how do you
fight fair in relationships
here's my rule for fighting
um you don't fight when you're mad
and you don't fight in the heat of
you have
I don't even honestly I'm gonna be I
don't like the word fighting
um there's passionate disagreements on
just fighting I fight when I'm trying to
protect somebody
um I fight when it with the intention of
hurting somebody and that's not how you
engage in relationship disagreements so
my rule is I don't fight when I'm mad I
don't disagree when I'm mad I walk away
I literally walk away sometimes it's for
30 minutes sometimes it's for 30 days
I'm not ready to have this conversation
yet I will come back and I'll be plugged
in
um and then when I come back in I'm very
specific I don't use words like
um
oh I'm very eye-centric I feel I'm
experiencing not you did and it's all
about here's what I'm bringing to the
table and then I ask my wife to bring
that back is that fair that's great okay
awesome you fight when you're mad
I'm learning not to really yeah way to
go because I'm I'm
as my husband lovingly calls me a bit of
a bulldozer I've never experienced that
yeah and so I just lied to America but
he needs to walk away and I usually am
you know Chase right after him but I am
learning to let him walk away we'll talk
think about it and then come back and
it's always more productive okay can I
ask you this question sure I have heard
it said that when somebody has the
maturity to walk away sometimes they say
this isn't a good conversation
that that in and of itself is like
dumping gasoline on a fire like oh
you're Mr mature and it just makes it
worse it can be definitely if if in my
case where I'm like oh okay well you
don't want to talk about this you know
blah blah but it
to me that was clear that I needed to do
more work than on me because
that person probably and you know later
you're like yeah that was the mature
choice so it was no I need to back up
I'm willing to be wrong here I don't I I
just don't have an experience in my life
we're fighting with somebody I love
solved anything no no it doesn't because
things you don't want to say come out
and yeah yeah you know accusations and
this that and the other so it never
works yeah
I'll leave it at that all right cool
this is not for me this is somebody else
but I'm just going to read the question
sure seriously 100 from tell me about
your marriage Kelly no my dad cheated on
my mom multiple times and now I'm
married I'm afraid my husband will cheat
on me can you Chief cheat proof a
marriage
hmm can you cheat proof of marriage I
don't know that that's the goal
um
the goal is to love deeply if you play a
game to not lose you're going to play
timid you're going to
um
uh you're going to be constricted I want
to play the game to win so
um number one her body is going to to
think he's gonna cheat and that's okay
what she's got to do is is be open about
that and be honest about it and say hey
in this season when I'm learning how to
trust and not just learning
intellectually but learning like my body
learning how to trust you
um here's what I need and he's got to
understand where she came from where her
the the world she comes from and say
okay I love you enough that I'm gonna
I'm gonna go a little bit further than
it makes sense even you can look at my
texts you can check out my Netflix
account here I'm a wide open book I'm
going to be a part of teaching her body
that she's safe and end man have a
regular check-in take care of yourselves
take care of each other and make it your
life's mission to meet the other
person's needs and if they make it their
life mission man it's really tough
you're done to go find love somewhere
else you don't need to all right you're
near
what's that sound oh I gotta tell you
that near story is pretty funny okay
it's not for today but it's awesome
how do you keep DIY home projects from
taking over your marriage
these don't ever do them don't do them
just stop
you know how many unfinished projects
here at my house 158
they're everywhere they're the worst a
don't don't B if you're going to have a
clear budget a clear I'm starting this
I'm going to finish it when a timeline
have enough people that can help you get
this thing started and finish it and you
cannot start any new project until this
one's finished period end of story and
this is the pot talking to the kettle
this is the single most hypocritical
thing I've ever said on the show don't
start anything until it's the other
thing's finished and if you're like but
I gotta do this cool sucks to be you you
got to finish the other thing first
that's just the way that's got to be and
you can't pull up all the hardwood
floors and be like I think I'm gonna
build a garden and then get halfway
through the garden and be like you know
what I need a pool and just start
shoveling in the backyard you can't do
it can't do it
that may be my favorite thing you've
ever said because you just
discussed my husband you just yeah if
you haven't got this by the way America
this is just like Kelly asked questions
about her marriage
the amount of Unfinished projects
anywho does he consider you an
unfinished project probably he's working
he's working hard I don't know if it's
going
so how do you know when a relationship
is worth fighting for uh
[Music]
um
you make the choice
to keep fighting for it
um when two when you you and the other
person are both all in if one person is
partly in and the other person's all in
it's not gonna work
um when you are doing things because you
need this you're codependent
um when somebody is an addict and they
are trying to keep themselves alive over
here with unhealthy behaviors and you're
tagging along it's not gonna work so
it's worth fighting for when both of you
say and not just say but both do
I'm I'm all in I gotta learn new stuff
and it's gonna take a long time I gotta
learn how to trust again I got to learn
how to fill in the blank I got to learn
how to handle money I gotta learn how to
not lie I gotta learn how to not drink
when I get upset or not overeat when I
get upset I gotta learn new things
but I promise I'm all in if you are
awesome
all right next question
how do you maintain intimacy when you
have small kids at home
you don't you don't if you have two kids
five and under
it's a sex-free zone for a long time
just kidding it's not
um here's how you uh number one
you have to do the seemingly unsexy
thing but it's absolutely not is you
have to plan intimacy and intimacy by
the way isn't just doing it intimacy is
also we're just I want you to sit by me
and hold me while we watch a show I want
to hold hands under the covers and fall
asleep together while we're watching the
office
um intimacy is I just want to sit on the
front porch and have coffee together
intimacy might be
bananas wild sex with all your weird
fantasy that's fine let's figure this
thing out I'll get off the rails tonight
like whatever that looks like but here's
the key you gotta be intentional about
it you gotta map it out and you have to
talk and so guys if you're like I lost
my wife shut up you're fine but speak
out loud and ladies if women if you're
like intimacy means something different
to me in this season
um I don't like all these people pawing
all over whatever that great speak it
out loud and then be very clear about
what comes next
awesome all right my husband has been
hinting that he might like to go to
therapy should I encourage him yes
yes
um I will tell you my wife has quote
unquote encouraged me
um there's been a couple of times in our
20-year marriage that she reached out to
my friends and said John's not okay and
these aren't just buddies that I work
with these are guys that are
um as close as brothers
um and so she's reached out to a few
guys in my life over the years and
they've reached out and said hey you're
not doing all right um what do you what
do you what actions are you going to
take
and um they've been strongly encouraging
now right now we're I'm gonna season in
my marriage when my wife actually she
told me the other day I think you need
to call that guy and she's right I need
to call that guy so
um now we're in a season where she just
encourages me and I can hear it there
was Seasons when I couldn't hear it if
she had told me to go to counseling I
would have blown up and been like you
need to go to counseling you're the
crazy person and so it just yes
absolutely should encourage him but
encourage him in a way that he can hear
it not in a way that makes you feel
better or feel like I said so that's not
that's not helpful
awesome
um I am
I have not been invited or included by
the wives of my husband's friend group
how do I handle that
I don't know are you weird
and this is a question to you Kelly
because then you just asked that
question
[Laughter]
um here's how you handle it um you got
rejected or you're getting rejected
you're in the act of getting rejection
one of the hardest things for married
couples especially newly married couples
is the expectation that you're just
going to be friends with their friend's
spouse
and that works for a season for a short
season occasionally you get to be pretty
tight but most of the time you have to
over time develop couple friends new
people that you hang out with and do
life with so if you realize that your
husband has some guy friends and their
wives are all buddy buddy and they don't
like you that stinks it hurts it's a
knife in your soul and more importantly
it's a knife in the picture of we're
just going to keep this party going we
are in college together and then we all
get married and now we're gonna have
kids together all gonna play Little
League together
they're not I know I'm still talking
they're not going to do that you're
gonna have to create new
um Community new friends so you're gonna
have to be honest with your husband and
he's going to be like no it's not true I
don't they like you they just
you have to be honest about it and
you've got to do the hard work of
finding other couple friends and going
out with them
man that stinks and it's not fun it's
the worst thing in the world is being an
adult making friends especially a couple
friends God help us but they are out
there and it's awesome just take some
work
add to that of course
um also because I have my group of
girlfriends and then
most of the husbands are friends as well
because we all met working in the same
industry and my husband is not a very
social person he's more of an introvert
and so he has expressed that same thing
at times and I said well the first few
times they asked you to do anything you
didn't so they quit asking
so at some point you may have to reach
out and say hey you want to go grab
coffee or so you may have to reach out
individually or with a couple of them
also that's a good point it may be
instead of doing like a couples thing
you reach out and ask those wives hey
let's all go out and I got three tickets
to the the XYZ
um let's all go and you just foot the
bill let's all take let's take them out
let's go do this but that's a great idea
all right last one
hold on you're smiling before you even
ask this I can see this and I don't know
what's coming I think this is a good
question that a lot of couples have and
by a lot you mean you and your husband
go ahead
how many times a week should a couple
have sex
yeah 10 11. I'm just kind of just
kidding
uh you're welcome gentlemen you're
welcome
um
man that okay so I get that question a
lot how often should a couple have sex
it's a couple different things number
one
um some people
the barometer for connectivity in the
relationship is sex that is that brings
peace to their body physiologically that
grounds them
um for some people it's Recreation for
some people it is
um it's a way to unplug and it's like
watching Lord of the Rings I can go be
somebody else do something else over
here we can become a different couple
over here because over here I wear a
suit and I go to work and I'm a dork and
I'm a mom I'm a dad over here I can get
off the rail so sex means different
things to different people and there's
different seasons in some Seasons I'm
writing a book and I'm really busy and
other Seasons man things are just
cooking and other Seasons we have a
two-year-old and a five-year-old and
then I'm pregnant so here's the thing
how many times you should you have sex
as many times as both of you can
honestly and fully
um commit to one another to doing it
over the course of one week two weeks
three weeks four weeks
um I think
kind of like weighing yourself uh every
day it's not it's not really a helpful
metric over time a trend is helpful so
if you get to the end of a week like we
only did it once this week we're falling
apart you're not if you get to the end
of
three months and we've had sex two or
three times and man I really am missing
my wife or I'm really missing my husband
what's going on
that is a trend right let's have that
conversation but
um I think it's what both people agree
on it's just that Kelly most people
agree on it they lie to each other I'm
cool I'm fine or no no it's good be
honest about your needs and figure it
out that way is that does that sound
fair yeah I think that's great okay
because I don't think there's a there's
not a numerical answer it's different
for everybody and I actually
um there is like a statistically most
couples have sex this often I'm actually
don't give that out because I every
couple is different and every couple has
diff is in a different season the same
as people are like what um what what
foods should you eat man that's a
that's it depends on what your goals are
and what you're doing it's got so many
factors to it so similar to that
question the key is be honest and
intentional about it
there we go you survived it that was it
that was it
those are fun thanks for setting that up
thanks for doing it